we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's go to our next caller from
the 7 to 4 area code caller what's your
name and where you calling from my name
is Alexander and my area code is from
Pittsburgh that I'm currently Minnesota
okay great
what's on your mind so my question for
you David is about another show that
does the liberal political commentary
it's redacted tonight with Lee camp are
you familiar with it I I know that it's
on arts and I've met Lee once before
although I don't know if I've ever seen
the show okay so my question about this
I love this show
but redacted tonight is part of our tea
and our tea does receive funding from
Russia for their news channel so my
question is with Russia's recent
involvement in the American political
system can i still trust our redacted
tonight to provide me with political
news if it receives funding from russia
brilliant brilliant question i mean the
specific answer is one that you're
probably better equipped to suss out
than me
in the sense that not being familiar
with the show I think I again I saw a
clip a couple years ago after I met Lee
at a conference you know I think your
instinct is correct to follow the money
and if you indeed have identified that
the same actor that sought to influence
American elections is funding the
programming that there's a significant
possibility of some kind of either
conflict of interest or attempt to
portray a particular narrative so I
think you're absolutely spot-on
now not being aware of number one you
know some arty shows the staff are are
actually arty staff and employees and
their relationship to arty would be
different than other shows where arty is
basically subcontracting the production
of a show so like Tom Hartman on arty
owns his show and from my conversations
with him he says that he is total
editorial control he's not an employee
of arty I have no clue what
situation is as far as that goes so I
think that your skepticism of what
you're getting is absolutely correct you
should apply the same skepticism to my
program into any other program that you
consume more specifically than that I'm
not really able to say because I don't
know both the financial arrangement as
well as the content of Lee's show all
right well thank you for that and I'd
like to say that I love your show and of
all the political commentary that I
consume yours is the most objective and
I appreciate that
all right well always a pleasure to take
calls from any of the great 50 states of
the United States